well I think first of all you have to
you have to think about the history of
other groups
assimilations as well usually they're
slow practices are adapted pragmatically
you have to begin by defining the
population as a symbol and it's unclear
to me that that Muslim Arab Northwest
Africans are considered ultimately
similar well I mean I think I have
something in in my book and in the
politics of the veil there's a moment
when a friend of mine who was opposed to
the headscarf ban was talking to a quite
famous Jewish politician and said to her
you know this is terrible and this woman
said to my friend well you know these
people are in a similar will and my
friend said well that's what they used
to say about the Jews and this woman was
just outraged and horrified but it's
historically it's true Jews where
anti-semitism was a tremendous problem
even for the most assimilated of French
Jews in the Dreyfus case and in the
1890s being an example of that so and
actually I just read a book by an
anthropologist a guy named John Bowen
who works on used to work on Indonesia
and now works on Muslims in France and
he spent a lot of time in a lot of these
little mosques all around and and just
hung out with people in cafes and
restaurants in them in the mosque and
what he describes in this book is a
process of assimilation that for any of
us whose parents or grandparents in my
case were came to America in this case
but were immigrants one can watch over
generations this process going on and
what he describes is the sort of
pragmatic adaptations that have to be
made so for example if by law in France
you have to get married in the City Hall
before you can have a religious wedding
mr. with Catholics sort of everybody and
a number of the constituents in one of
these mosques says well they don't know
if they even want to get married they'll
just go have a mosque wedding and
that'll be a more hollow way of doing
the wedding or they'll get married there
first and then they'll don't comply with
and the Imam says well you know you
could do that if you want to but since
there are no Sharia Courts in France if
anyone wants to get a divorce and he
says this to the women particularly if
you want to get a divorce you will have
no recourse to a Sharia Court there will
be no one to judge your situation if you
don't have a civil marriage you won't be
able to get a divorce and so you're
gonna be stuck in a very difficult sort
of situation of course I'm not
predicting that this will happen to you
but and so they do they get married in
the civil courts should they come to the
Imam and they say they want to buy a
house but they go there are no Islamic
banks in France should can they borrow
money from a bank at interest well he
says you know it's probably more
important for you to have a stable place
for your family to live than to deal
with this interest thing so we can
reinterpret what you're paying as a
different kind of interest at that it uh
or is one thing taking priority over the
other and so they go and borrow money
and it just and so it goes these stories
of adaptation you're not allowed to
slaughter goats in your bathtub in the
and the housing projects in which people
live so you they they find
interpretations in the Quran which say
you can give money to charity instead of
sacrificing an animal at the end of
Ramadan and so what's astonishing about
the book is the slow and pragmatic way
that people are adopting two rules of
sort of both social and political life
in France they are assimilating and what
he says at the end of the book is that
the French government is far less
accommodating on the other side isn't as
attuned to this process of assimilation
as it has been in past times when
Portuguese or Italians or you know other
groups Jews have come and found their
ways slowly over several generations of
of assimilating you know most you're not
even talking in the muslim populations
of the majority being practicing
being sort of Orthodox in their in their
practices so I think the process is
happening and it should be allowed to
happen I would draw the line I mean when
groups come into schools and say they
don't want just as I would be here and
what they don't want
evolution taught in the in the science
curriculum or they want a different kind
of history taught I mean it seems to me
there are lines that one can draw about
what is the sort of the way we do things
here and what are the openings to the
the needs and interests of the
Constituent groups I mean in schools I
would certainly say they have to teach
the history of colonialism and of Empire
in a different way from the way it's
been taught and that that is not a
matter of a concession to religion it's
a matter of being more inclusive in the
kind of history that is taught and
there's that's written so it depends but
I mean I think there are certainly lines
that one can draw which don't involve
capitulation to theocracy which is what
the what has always held out you know if
we let them wear headscarves or burgers
will become Iran tomorrow and I don't
think there's any danger that France
will become around turkey might be a
different story where you're talking
about a 90% Muslim population it's a
different set of problems and issues
there but in countries in which these
groups are minorities I think you know
then I become a kind of champion of
American multiculturalism it seems to me
we've we've done it right in a way that
is in allowing a certain kind of
tolerance or I wouldn't even call it
tolerance recognition of the differences
that people bring with them even as at
least as long as people are not having
to read Texas textbooks but as long as
there's a kind of an educational system
that in into which they or through which
they become
participants in the democratic processes
of the country